l'un deux hectares réaménager le futur
quartier des savoirs s'inscrit dans le
projet urbain du grand paris express
avec l'arrivée de la ligne 18 du métro
ce quartier situé au sud de la ville est
basé sur les anciennes friches de thales
accueillera environ 2000 logements mais
aussi des entreprises et des commerces
c'est une réelle opportunité pour la
ville de bus en cours parce que on
souhaite en faire un quartier absolument
exemplaire dans toutes ses dimensions
qu'elles soient environnementale en
termes de transition écologique en terme
de mixité fonctionnelle une mixité
sociale
le 13 mars prochain une concertation en
visioconférence sera lancée avec tous
les acteurs et partenaires de ce projet
notamment l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay mais aussi
tous les habitants qui le souhaitent
cette concertation durera environ trois
ans on va avoir des ateliers thématiques
des balades urbaines sur site enregistre
dématérialisée également où les gens
vont pouvoir exposer leurs leur demande
leurs questions dans ce nouveau quartier
des équipements publics viendront
s'ajouter comme un groupe scolaire un
gymnase des espaces verts et aquatiques
et aussi des locaux associatifs certains
aménagements sont d'ores et déjà établi
ce qui est déjà acté c'est le
positionnement de la gare on le sait
maintenant c'est certain
à l'angle nord est de la parcelle du
quartier des savoirs ce qui est acté
également c'est la présence de ce grand
bois au sud de la parcelle avec cette
espace aquatique
nous allons également conserver et nous
en sommes très fiers l'allemagne au
piano le coût total de ce nouveau
quartier avoisinera la centaine de
millions d'euros
la première pierre sera posée entre 2025
et 2030 6